كذلك هؤلاء الذين بدلوا ارواحهم في سبيل
ايضا هذه البلاد من الشهداء ايضا هؤلاء
لهم حق علينا ما في في منطقه من مناطق
المملكه الا وكانت لابائهم واجدادهم
مساهمه ولهذا اتخذ ايضا الاسره السعوديه
كرمز لهم ايضا من خلال هذه السنوات
الطويله اكثر من 300 سنه الى يومك الحاضر
فلابد الحقيقه ان يستشعر الجميع ايضا
ويستشعر بمهيه هذا الامر الذي نعيش فيه
ونتفيؤلاء
يعني عدد الناس اللي ضحوا بحياتهم او ببعض
اعضائهم او بغير ذلك من اموالهم في سبيل
صد الغزاه الاجانب في وسط البلاد وجنوبها
وشمالها كل مكان شقراء في الراس فيضرما في
ابها في يعني حملات لتصدى لها الابطال وهي
ليست وليده اليوم يعني الامام محمد بن
سعود عند قيام ايضا هذه الدوله فهو صراعهم
على الرياض استشهد من ابنائه ايضا الامام
سعود وفيصل اوائل الابناء الذين استشهدوا
ايضا في سبيله وغيرهم ايضا من هذه الاسره
كلهم مستشهد وايضا في سبيل توحيد البلاد
وتحقيق الامن
طيب محمد بن سعود لذلك